zach going to an 816 era i'll be a short
leash with him because you know he
hasn't had a good start for a while but
we'll see curveballs not a lot of
fastballs a lot of curveballs as
mccutchen gets ready to dig in
one
two oh made a nice pitch struck him out
he catches mccutcheon admiring that one
away it was a good start there for godly
ethel and john his numbers against the
the american league have gotten better
and better over the last couple years
roduko's hit safely in eight consecutive
games
swing at a miss that's a sinker that
rolled outside and verdugo is down on
strikes alexander just four for his last
30. have failed ever is the man at
second
and a base hit shot to right field
evers hits third here he comes here's
harper's throw to the plate and they're
not going to get him he dives in the rbi
single by xander bogarts and the red sox
lead in one to nothing two outs and
here's mitch moreland swinging a miss
struck him out fastballed up and away
and moreland goes down on strikes couple
of strikeouts in the first for effluent
jay bruce 227 with three home runs 3-2
pitch swinging a miss good action to
that sinker down and away and bruce fans
sets the second strike out by godly the
runner at second two down for scott
kingry
swung on and missed good pitch there by
godly back-to-back hayes one man left
michael
chavis
and a foul tip and a strikeout that's
the third of the night for effluent zoo
way lynn
movement on that pitch
i would hope victor i would
that was a good pitch i mean that thing
started probably at the hip of a righty
and ended up a ball down and then if you
didn't swing here's kevin plawecki the
hitter
and a strike three called after the
lead-off walk he gets the next three
hitters five strikeouts for zach f went
through two at eight roman quinn will
lead off
got him with a breaking ball four
strikeouts for godly so alex right at
280 five home runs
i think david loved it that one driven
high toward the wall is going to be off
the top of that ledge and drop right
down to mccutcheon
and into second base for a nine-game
hitting streak is alex ferdugo you're
talking about a fenway double in the
scoring position for rafael devers who
singled and scored a run the only run of
the game in the first inning 1-1
fly ball two left center field that
one's well hit and that one is a wall
scraper so devers is into second with a
wall double verdugo scores
back to back doubles to start the inning
and the red sox lead two to nothing
jd's old for one
trying to run it inside that's a fair
ball
down the line to the corner that'll
score raffy devers
and that's three consecutive red sox
doubles as martinez trots into second
boston leads at 3-0
zander with an rbi single in the first
inning
swinging a miss six strikeouts for
effluent and that's the first out here
in the third and then cd gregorius up
he's over one he fly to left his first
at-bat
that one's hooked down the right field
line and it's over the head of pilar and
off the wall dede has hit it eight
straight jay bruce is the hitter
that one's pulled into right field of
base hit
dd's to third he's being waved home the
throw will be cut off by mitch morwin
it's an rbi single jay bruce's eighth
rbi of the year and the phillies are on
the board but michael chavis leads off
0-2 pitch
and that's a call strike three davis now
looking zooey lynn
missy that's eight strikeouts for evan
ferguson's
up out toward right field that's pretty
well hit pilar going back toward the
wall it is gone off the top of the wall
and into the seats
a solo home run for reese
his first of the year and it goes the
opposite way it's a 3-2 game
oh how beautiful is that he gets a
change or two-seamer on the outside part
upper third
he stays on it and just like the double
in the gap with the bases loaded against
the mets he stays
level with his hips doesn't drop him
doesn't drop his shoulder stays on top
with a nice tough hand phil gosling is
going to stand in and bat for scott
kingery
that ball is drilled out toward left
center field and it's off the monster
and phil gosling with an rbi double and
it's again a one-run game well here's
roman quinn who's over two that one's
pulled down the left field lot it's a
fair ball verdugo gets to it quickly but
gosselin is going to score and the
phillies have tied it up on an rbi
single andrew mccutchen will be first to
face him and the pitch
mccutcheon swings and lines it fair pass
third again kicks off the sidewall again
but it's a base hit to give the phillies
the lead andrew mccutchen with an rbi
single another rocket pass third and
it's five to four phillies harper 0 for
three and on base street see if he can
keep it going right here with two men on
and two out
that one is pulled deep to right field
pilar going back it is gone
then to the back of the red sox bullpen
and then into the stands
it's a three-run home run the phillies
lead it eight to four well he was
frustrated on that foul ball frustrated
though no more
no stride
there was no extra added into that it
was just a nice effortless swing goslin
who came off the bench that now remained
in the game at second base
there we go again that one's out toward
the monster and it is gone
into the first row
a solo home run for phil gosselin
he's two for two off the bench
10-4 phillies
here is jay bruce
out to center field
going back on it is lynn back to the
wall and it is gone
just over the wall and straight away
center field jay bruce his fourth home
run of the year it's also his fourth rbi
of the night it's 13-5
we'll put another man on down to third
goes moreland chavis will get another
chance
swagger to miss he can strike out five
times in the game not that you'd want to
see anybody do it but he just did
and the ball game is over the phillies
have won four straight as they take game
one by a final score of 13-6
over the red sox